it's time for puppy pig skin picks it is
sponsored by subaru of las vegas
we have kelsey with us this morning hi
kelsey good morning
good morning how did you bring today
this is comet and as you can see he
takes treats very gently he's about
eight years old
he's 70 pounds he's a big boy you might
be intimidated by him but he is just a
snuggle bug
he's actually in a foster home right now
so we do know a lot about him we know
that
uh he gets along with other dogs in the
home as well yeah and the foster mom is
here too he's like mommy
come back he's a really good dog and
tell us a little bit about the foster
program because some people who can't
make maybe the whole commitment
that's a really good option it's a great
option you can take home
a dog or cat for just a couple weeks and
it gets them out of the shelter they
really shouldn't be in the shelter they
want to be at your home
on a couch and we're able to learn so
much about the animal in just those
couple weeks what kind of personality
they have and
you know what find the best option for
them in terms of a great adopter
and you guys have a special going on
this weekend correct so we do
have a special for the big game it's
called the
tailgate promotion emphasis on tail and
so
common and other animals their fees are
waves so it's adult cats
and large adult dogs just like comments
that is awesome all right comet
well we hope we get you a great home but
right now it's time to pick we got the
bucks
and the chiefs let's see who he goes for
that's the buccaneers all right he went
for tom brady
comet is so sweet too adopting a pet in
foster care is a bit different so to
learn more about it or make an
appointment
just email foster animal foundation dot
com
we've also got that on our website but
it's a great way to get the dogs cats
you know into your home give them some
love they're very sweet
all right